let's talk about collaboration I think
as just in general we have talked about
how Internet has changed the world and
how it's made lots of things possible
and collaboration of all sorts is
something that should be very thankful
to the Internet and as we think about
where translation is headed where
technology is headed in general which
affects this crowd and this space I
think collaboration is something that's
very fundamentally changing how a lot of
business models work and a really great
example of how collaboration has really
created some amazing business value an
amazing user value is search every time
you go and search for something and you
select the first or the second or the
third or the end result you're basically
providing some information that's going
to help somebody else that comes after
you so that's a very collaborative
technology and we should what what I
wanted to talk about today is how that
technology how collaboration in general
effects translations and our approach to
collaborative translations so just to
give you a little bit of an overview of
Microsoft translator our service it's a
statistical machine translation system
it's available as a cloud cloud service
I think several of you in this room have
probably called the API and are or use
the site so Bing Translator is the end
user focused offering of the technology
it powers millions of translations every
day everything from Microsoft products
like office internet explorer but most
recently facebook
and so we've been constantly adding new
languages and like Chris said I think we
have covered a lot of the major
languages but the smaller ones either
will require a very specific dedicated
collaborative effort like Haitian Creole
did or more data sharing so that there
is actually some data to train on we
also have a very broad set of AP ice and
that in turn enable a lot of different
kinds of scenarios so we also have one
of the announcements that we had made
over the last few weeks is that we have
added higher volume paid subscription
service for for the API so we are today
I think the only remaining really large
scale machine translation service that
continues to have a free API and then we
also have the paid API for people who
want to try in fact anyone who wants to
actually try the higher volumes we it's
it's basically free for the first four
months right now okay so let's let's go
and look at what are the keys to making
collaborative technology actually work
right so the first thing and this is
this is very fundamental to pretty much
anything that you do in software or
services you want to focus on the right
thing so this is not really about
getting feedback from the user it's
really all about really enabling
understanding well that's what
ultimately you're trying to do with
translation is somebody is going to try
to understand what you're going to
present to them and that's what you want
to be focused on so in some cases like
Bill was mentioning yesterday you may
want to you know that the user might be
willing to actually take some extra
effort to understand it and in some
cases they may just walk away if they
don't understand it so really keep that
focus on understanding and think about
what scenarios does it actually apply
then you want to deliver immediate value
what's really important is that in the
in in the past there always used to be
this okay come and give us feedback if
you don't like this translation you know
go over here and tell us what you think
it should have been but most of the time
that really doesn't work very well the
user has to be very motivated to to come
and give you that feedback what you
really want to focus on is how do you
give the user and incentive to give you
that feedback right on Wikipedia users
have an incentive to do something
because you know they feel like they are
doing some good or they're contributing
on you know in a game the user is going
to do a lot of things because they are
trying to go towards a goal and all
along the way if it's a lot of work they
will still put in that work in our
situation where we are trying to deliver
translations you want to give them
something in order to in order for them
to give you something back and so you
will see how we we are trying to help
the user immediately when when they give
you give us some feedback we try to help
the user and the users community
hopefully the user that comes after the
user immediately then the third part and
this is I mean I have to stress this
there are there are a lot of companies
that you know don't see this as being
that valuable especially if you are
number one but partnering is really
really critical right you don't really
always know what the user wants you
can't be the expert about every kind of
scenario every kind of use case so you
need to really partner with the people
who really care about this user
understanding so in many cases what we
are we are just a tool where we are
basically providing tools and frameworks
to those like say a website owner or
someone a developer which building an
app and giving them the tools to ensure
that they are able to deliver the
understanding to the user
be flexible right so you want to be able
to give whoever it is that you're
partnering with whether it is directly
with the user or with a site owner or a
Content owner you want to be able to
give them what they need we want to give
them a bunch of Lego bricks that they
can put together into something that
works for them so you know in the
translation case they may want to use
dynamic translation or they may want to
publish something or they may want to
mix them and you want to be flexible and
ensure choice so you want to give them
so if I am if I'm a company that has
websites and apps and and and services I
want to be able to use this technology
across all of them and if my users are
giving me feedback I want that to help
all of them so make sure that this is
this is something that goes across all
scenarios and that's where api's and
kind of shared cloud-based services
really help and also make sure that it's
easy for people to kick your tires right
that's part of why we want to continue
to keep offering the free service and
there are also some many scenarios where
you know there is no volume for there to
be revenue and in in many of these
situations there are still users on the
other end and ultimately you want to
stay portable lots of people have warmed
up to cloud services but as they have
warmed up to cloud services they have
also gotten very wise to the needs of
portability and so make sure that the
data is free it's your data you should
be able to take it out of there and go
somewhere else or use it in some other
way so those were some of the tenets
that really drove the vision of the
collaborative translations framework so
let's look at these a little bit in
detail so collaborative so you want
immediate benefit I'm just repeating
some of these things for for effect
owners
should have control we don't know the
user is better than the owners of these
scenarios do and it needs to be
collaborative so users help other users
users help the community community's
help other communities those are some of
the very fundamental aspects of crowd
and collaborative technologies
translations give them an option to
override the machine translation so
that's one of the key parts of this if
you have a better translation have there
be a mechanism in which your translation
wins so we have a couple of API is very
simple API is called add translations
and get translations which really do
much of this heavy lifting and then you
can export your edits if you like and
it's a framework so you can integrate it
into your workflow your scenario you can
use it in your apps you can use it
within your tools you can build it into
the tool that you sell to somebody else
and you can define your own ratings and
your own user management so that you're
not tied to live ID or some Microsoft
proprietary sign-in mechanism and from a
extensibility standpoint you can use it
as an API but say you are a small
website owner who doesn't really want to
go start developing a lot of code you
know you may want to have some sort of
out-of-the-box solution so we have that
too so let's take a look at an example
so Lake Washington School District is
the school district in the Seattle area
very very good school district when I
was buying a house I had to really look
for a house that would fall into the
right school zones and all and it was
all new to me but having worked with
these guys I knew already in preparation
that this was a good school district so
the interesting thing is you know the
Seattle area is very cosmopolitan and
it's there are a lot of parents of the
students who don't actually have very
fluent English
so they they might prefer to communicate
in another language i would like to
consume content another language so so
this is this was an interesting problem
because this was not really a rich you
know school district that has lots and
lots of budget to localize everything
they have to send newsletters out and
there's a lot of kind of dynamic content
and so they wanted some mechanism to
deliver reasonable quality translations
so so we have one scenario built on top
of the API called the web widget it's
the it's it's a very simple no code
solution and what it does is basically
you can put it on your web page you can
translate the web page and then you can
basically hover over the sentences that
have been translated to look at
alternatives provide alternatives and
and and if you have a role that you have
been assigned authoritative role you can
go and approve them so I'll give a quick
demo